welcome to this video playing Grand
Master krupa originally from the Ukraine
I guess and is now playing here for for
Jordan from the Jordan flag think it's
um maybe it's some training job wire
something that he's got ok we have a
sloth exchange the slot exchange some
opening that I always have played yeah
as wide as a good solid choice it's also
just a matter of alternatives and this
love is a very solid opening and I never
really found something that was so great
that I needed to replace the exchange
okay so he played them an early Queen
maneuver to get my picture back to the
seven so that it's not out of the pawn
chain but this is in fact not such a big
problem I am I can get some play on the
sea far with the b5 possibilities I only
I need to be a be cautious that it's not
weakening too much with a four and so on
it can play against the b5 it was a bit
annoying is this pressure on age 7 and
that of course i'd like to get rid of
the the night here I wonder is this is a
move here we should be five getting rid
of this bishop he didn't
and since it is interesting never seen
this this idea and then the Slovaks
change the question is is this a serious
weakness or not yeah exactly queen bee
62 screen b6 over this is giving away
the poem sorry need to play before
stupid me of course I need to play
before yeah but it is a weakness night a
force an interesting move
mmm you have the night as soon as
offside but be successor as a sensitive
square head sir it's a bit tricky in for
like 27 for instance a sir Knight b6 27
the saying of course not 197 let's say
it can take a dive basics
here are three to be five is also a
serious issue so i can wear concrete
idea i just want to prevent queen bee
five of course giving away the C file is
nothing that is to take a lightly but
this was my idea that i have no c 3 as a
possible spot for counter play
right beehive c3 is something like that
yeah this is also a 97 on this is a
really really annoying idea thought this
this could be a good good idea against
that the checking of the night and after
he takes Knight b5 the night is still
having this in this ideas on c3 and the
night on b5 also protects his seven so
it's a it's a good quite a good position
now it's curious that he's thinking
because the light was saying so didn't
think he had really had something to to
consider but okay I don't know quite
interesting
hmm one of those moves that really are
that are not so easy to see because you
don't really think about putting
something on c8 but could be strong f6r
add the night only five is such an
annoying piece rook f7 wow this is a
very unusual kind of piece set up 95 how
do I protect the pole
hmm not at all I guess
oh wait 'if I've takes and drug c7 is a
nap in now be 693 ok I can take me five
oops you can check be five hmm
yeah I just got 93 m time warning black
resigned yeah this was this was really
interesting I thought I was rather
optimistic here thinking about this 93
idea but night c8 is of course quite a
good move I think
yeah his pieces are really in really
nicely positioned here probably f6 is
bad but the computer already gives wider
close to the size of advantage the
alcohol I mean I've got a bad night only
five it's not that's clear but it still
needs a good timing i mean it can easily
happen that can night see a tower 98
strong just using this is temp oh I'm
misplacing my piece yeah maybe the
special b5 idea wasn't so great at all
yeah yeah here the computer wants to
play night before I thought about that
this is in fact interesting I didn't
mention it in the common treatment I was
thinking about this this idea the ideas
after this it takes to have this this
option but here but it's not working and
can take and take on b5 but the computer
points out this move and this is in fact
interesting because now I'm he's late
he's got slight problem see if he lets
it takes and place this I've got I've
got this meal according to the comb with
this yeah okay I cannot play this in a
blitz game I mean this is not not so
easy even in a tournament game getting
for this positional compensation but
okay it's clear that now his night is
the off side piece something like this
while the gabby outplayed me nicely I
thought Bitsy's free with
an interesting game I hope you enjoyed
it